tens of thousands of brazilians took to
the streets
for the third time in five weeks
since may they've been calling for
president jair bolsonaro's impeachment
they accused him of scorning health
measures to contain the covid19 outbreak
allowing the virus to spread and kill
more than 520
000 people brazil has the world's second
largest covid19 death toll
after the united states while americans
have more than enough vaccines to go
around brazilians are sadly lacking
with less than 13 percent of its
population
fully inoculated patricia ribeiro
says her 42 year old brother would be
alive
if the government had not refused to buy
the 17 million vaccines pfizer
offered last year
my brother's death last march could have
been avoided we found out that the
government could have vaccinated
thousands of people earlier but chose
not to
because the president said the disease
was a little flu now we find out there
was also corruption
for the past two months a senate
committee has been investigating the
government's handling of the pandemic
last week the probe took a turn for the
first time raising suspicions
that some bolsonaro allies and health
ministry insiders
may be involved in a corruption scheme
to buy overpriced vaccines from india on
friday the supreme court authorized
the opening of an investigation into
bolsonaro's response
the president is being accused of
dereliction of duty
since he was warned of alleged
irregularities in the deal
but did not tell the federal police
growing discontent with the government
resulted in a nationwide protest
calling for bolsonaro's impeachment but
this time
opponents have new ammunition until now
protesters have accused president jair
bolsonaro
of downplaying the virus of delaying the
rollout of vaccines
now they're saying it's not denial
it's corruption more than 120
impeachment requests have been submitted
[Music]
none of them have moved forward because
bolsonaro still has enough support in
congress
and also on the streets where he has led
three motorbike rallies
but the president's popularity has taken
a severe blow
his approval rate has fallen to a record
23 percent
putting at risk bolsonaro's hope of
being re-elected next year
monika al jazeera rio de janeiro